IMPEACHMENT IF THEY ARE NOT SENT
TO THE SENATE WITHIN 25 DAYS OF
THEIR ADOPTION.
SEND THE ARTICLES OR HE WILL
START THE IMPEACHMENT TRIAL
WITHOUT HER PERMISSION.
FIRST I WANT TO APPLAUD YOU.
THE IDEA WE WILL JUST HOLD THEM
INDEFINITELY.
WE WILL LECTURE THE SENATE HOW
THEY WILL DO THEIR BUSINESS OR
ARGUING THE PRESIDENT IS NOT THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
THAT MEANS THAT IF I READ MY
DATES ARE RIGHT, THIS CASE CAN
BE DISPOSED OF BY JANUARY 11th.
AM I READING THAT RIGHT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THIS IS DAY 19.
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT.
THE HOUSE SPEAKER IS TRYING TO
RUN THE UNITED STATES SENATE.
SHE IS TRYING TO HIJACK THE
TRIAL AND OBSTRUCT THE TRIAL.
SHE IS SUBVERTING THE
CONSTITUTION.
THE CONSTITUTION IS CLEAR.
THE HOUSE HAS THE POWER TO
IMPEACH.
THEY HAVE DONE THAT.
THE SENATE HAS THE POWER TO TRY
THE CASE.
IT'S TIME FOR THE SENATE TO
FIGHT BACK.
>> Sean: WHAT HAPPENED TO ALL OF
THE URGENCY IT HAD TO BE DONE IN
RECORD TIME?
>> EXACTLY.
WE HEARD HOW URGENT IT WAS THE
PRESIDENT HAD TO BE REMOVED.
THE ONLY URGENCY ON THE PART OF
THE DEMOCRATS AND PELOSI WAS TO
PURSUE THEIR PERSONAL VENDETTA
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY NEVER ACCEPTED HIS
ELECTION.
THEY NEVER WANTED HIM IN OFFICE.
THEY WANTED TO GET HIM OUT.
NOW WHEN IT'S TIME TO PUT UP OR
SHUT UP AND PUT THEIR EVIDENCE
FORWARD THEY ARE AFRAID TO DO IT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
EVIDENCE.
IT'S A JOKE AND A FRAUD.
>> Sean: THEY HAD ALL OF THEIR
WITNESSES.
THE HOUSE MANAGER IS SUPPOSED TO
PRESENT THEIR CASE BEFORE THE
SENATE BASED WHAT THEY CAME UP.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT NO WE
WANT TO ADD OTHER WITNESSES THEY
DIDN'T CALL OR FIGHT TO GET.
TO ME, THEY ARE ASKING NOW THE
SENATE TO DO THE JOB THEY SHOULD
HAVE DONE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY.
WHEN YOU ELIMINATE OPINION
WITNESSES, YOU ONLY HAVE ONE
FACT WITNESS.
THAT WAS AMBASSADOR SONLAND.
WHAT DID THE PRESIDENT?
NOTHING.
I WANT NO QUID PRO QUO.
IT'S A SLAM DUNK AND THE IDEA OF
AN OBSTRUCTION CHARGE WHEN THERE
IS A CONFLICT BETWEEN THE
EXECUTIVE AND LEGISLATIVE BRANCH
AND THEY SEEK REMEDY THROUGH THE
JUDICIARY AND THE SUPREME COURT
IS REVIEWING, THAT'S NOT REASON
OBSTRUCTION.
>> NO, NEVER HAS IT BEEN IN THE
PAST.
THEY HAVE NO CASE AND THEY KNOW
IT.
THEY ARE AFRAID TO PROCEED TO A
TRIAL.
THE SENATE IS READY TO HAVE A
THE PRESIDENT DESERVES TO HAVE A
TRIAL.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE TO
HAVE A TRIAL TO PUT THIS TO
REST.
AND SPEAKER PELOSI WANTS TO GO
ON FOR WHO KNOWS HOW LONG?
>> Sean: THEY WANT TO LIVE IN A
CONSTANT STATE OF IMPEACHING THE
PRESIDENT.
WHERE IS MITT ROMNEY?
WHERE IS MURKOWSKI AND ALEXANDER
AND SUSAN COLLINS?
>> I CAN'T SPEAK FOR ANYBODY BUT
MYSELF.
WHEN I INTRODUCED MY RESOLUTION,
WE GOT 10 CO-SPONSORS IN THE
SENATE.
THE SENATE IS SICK AND TIRED OF
WHAT THE HOUSE IS DOING AND SICK
AND TIRED OF THE DEMOCRATS
ANTICS AND READY TO STAND UP FOR
THE CONSTITUTION.
I BELIEVE THEY WILL.
>> Sean: GOOD FOR YOU, SENATOR.
BETWEEN YOU AND LINDSEY GRAHAM
AND OTHERS, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS NOT A GAME.
THEY HAVE LOWERED THE BAR FOR
IMPEACHMENT TO SPITTING ON THE
SIDEWALK OR JAY WALKING.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US.
REACTION HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE MEMBER AND A FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
JASON, WE GAVE GATES MY RADIO
MICROPHONE.
WE CAN'T PAY HIM.
HE DID IT FOR FREE.